[Music]
with their moans groans and screams
[Music]
Hollywood's mummies have always given us
chill
[Music]
but this week researchers in England let
us hear what a real mummy sounds like
that's the voice of Nessie amoun an
Egyptian priest who lived 3,000 years
ago scientists were able to mimic Nessie
a moons voice by recreating his mouth
and vocal chords with the 3d printer it
allowed them to produce a single sound
Nessie a moon was chosen for this
research because his remains were well
preserved during mummification and also
because there are inscriptions in his
coffin about his hope to speak again
after death a desire from the ancient
world fulfilled by modern technology the
limit of how many times I could that's
pretty good Wow mummys tongue okay folks
let me get this get through with this
just glad the Mummy's tongue muscles had
deteriorated so much over time that they
could not be scanned or copied but but
scientists hope that this technology can
someday be used to recreate a living
person's voice so it's the tone the
pitch type of it yes exactly not create
words without having the talk yes it's
fascinating nice job